Speaker 1: Let's go to Willie from Oregon.
Willie, welcome to the show.
What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hey, I was just curious if you
have paid any attention to the truth.
Social ads started popping up.
Speaker 1: No.
We just did a story earlier this week about
how a company that was going to invest 140
million to merge with truth social, they're
just completely bailing.
And Truth Social is likely going to fail soon.
But where are they running?
Ads.
Speaker 2: Well, there was an update to the
app, and so I did that.
And also I noticed that these ads started
popping up like and that.
It looks like Trump's only one paying for
ads just painted by Biden.
Okay, there's one for, you know, 2500 free
knives and reason through that was like, arm
yourselves.
Oh, my goodness.
Now, let me ask you this pretty dark.
Speaker 1: Are you one?
When you're on the app, do you just look to
see the wacky stuff that gets posted?
Are you on there to kind of like argue with
people or to troll?
Like, what's your what do
you do on the app?
Speaker 2: Oh.
Could be class on this or.
Speaker 1: No, no, please don't.
Speaker 2: Okay.
Just messing with Troutman and following the
cuckoo.
Speaker 1: They're crazy.
Have you had anybody, like, directly attack
you because of the things you post?
Speaker 2: Oh, yeah, I did
that for a little bit.
You know, I there's not much common sense
on there, so it's kind of pointless to do
anything, but just like to keep an eye on
what that guy is up to and talking.
And like, you know, last night, it looked
like he just reposts the craziest stuff, and
it's pretty scary.
Well, I like to keep an eye on him, see what
he's up to.
But
the
that you should look at some
of the
ads
that
have
been popping up on there.
They're very strange.
Speaker 1: I'll check that out.
I'll check that out.
Thanks for bringing it to my attention.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
I think it's worth looking
into and talking about a
little bit.
All right.
Speaker 1: Willie, for more on that.
Very much appreciate it.
Thank you very, very much.
Really, really important stuff happening.
Untruth.
And it soon should fail completely.
All right.
Okay.
Let's take a very quick break.
If you're holding to talk to me, keep holding,
because we're going right back to the phones
in a moment.